looking to host your own website blog or
e-commerce site today we'll be
introducing you to the lab running
WordPress on App Engine flexible
environment in this lab you'll get to
setup and recognize all the benefits of
WordPress on Google cloud platform
WordPress is one of the most popular
open source content management systems
and GCP can help you run your website in
an effective and scalable manner by
using App Engine we can make sure that
your website scales to any number of
viewers quickly and automatically Google
Cloud sequel and Google Cloud Storage
will let you host your database and
files using management infrastructure so
you don't need to worry about resizing
virtual machines or emergency downtime
requests basic knowledge of PHP and
Linux text editors will be required to
finish this lab on quick labs first in
this lab you'll make sure all the
appropriate services are enabled then
you'll set up App Engine and cloud
sequel to host the website and database
separately you'll also use Google Cloud
Storage to host your media library at
the end of the lab you'll know how to
fully deploy a WordPress website on GCP
you'll be using a student and GCP
account to work on these labs but if you
want to get started with your own
account
here's $300 to get you started today
I'll answer a question from Vinny Ock
hedge on YouTube he asks don't you have
any tutorials for GCP IOT core I am
trying to send data from my order we
know to GCP but I am unable to do it as
I'm not aware how to send data using
MQTT great question we've got some start
our open source code on github that can
help you connect your Arduino devices to
GCP check the link below in the
description for more information
we also have tons of tutorials on Google
Cloud IRT core including an Internet of
Things QuickStart lab click on the link
in the description below to check them
out and get started we'll catch you next
time on Google cloud labs
[Music]